[Music]
homie look what I become
all right buddy Make Some Noise let's go
ladies
and gentlemen tonight we have a very
very special event many are calling 2024
the most momentous election in a
generation it will dictate where the
future of America is heading tonight
valuetainment is hosting our first town
hall with a candidate that is surging in
the polls like no one expected and is
capturing the imagination of Voters all
across the country that being said
ladies and Gentlemen please help me
welcome to the stage my friend and CEO
of valuetainment Patrick Bet David
foreign
[Applause]
[Music]
if you don't live here the traffic here
from Miami up to Fort Lauderdale is
similar to La sometime but we're glad to
have uh the man in the house I'm going
to show you some data about what he's
done since the last time we did podcasts
together which I believe was January
13th he doesn't even know I want to be
showing these numbers too but let me
properly introduce to you tonight's yes
our guest is a
biopharmaceutical entrepreneur Harvard
grad who earned his JD at Yale law
school while attending Harvard he was an
internet Goldman Sachs in 2014 he
founded the pharmaceutical company
royban Sciences a company created to
purchase patents from larger
pharmaceutical companies something we'll
be talking about tonight for drugs that
had not yet been successfully developed
and bring them to the market in 2022 he
co-founded stripe asset management and
investment firm that opposes ESG some of
you are aware of ESG you're not happy
about ESG he co-founded our company just
to strictly fight against it he's
written three books woke Inc nations of
victim capitalist punishment Capital
capitalist punishment and oh my goodness
show these Twitter numbers I can't wait
for you to see the Twitter numbers
mind-boggling when you see these Twitter
numbers according to every single poll
he went from no one knowing who he was a
year ago if I asked you a year ago who
is Vivek ramaswani you would say I have
no clue the only people who knew who he
was is his wife his two kids his loved
ones his co-workers his family his peers
his classmates his acquaintances and his
competitors today the world is following
what he's been doing in politics and
it's exciting he's one of the six
Republican president presidential
candidates who's qualified for the first
Republican primary debate by meeting the
polling and donor threshold established
by the Republican National Committee and
as of June 19th he has raised 19.1
million dollars Daily Mail article said
the entrepreneur and political novice
has caught up
we're in the State of Florida so don't
get upset because he is from Ohio so
just take it easy on him till Florida
Governor Ron DeSantis with both 2024
candidates tied for second after former
president Donald Trump in GOP poll
ladies and Gentlemen please help me
welcome The One and Only from Cincinnati
Ohio Vivek ramaswani
excited to have you you know I I want I
want the audience to hear from you first
book before they do I want to show
something here because your data guys
businessman you know we like data right
so I said guys January 13 when we did
the podcast how many Twitter followers
did vivec have I don't know if you know
how many you had I don't you were on 113
000 Rivals we can pull this up then I
said I want us to compare him versus all
the other Republican candidates who's
performed the best plus minus you know
we like plus minus of course buy the
number of followers and percentage-wise
here's what it looks like Rob if you
want to pull it up here's what we found
out okay here's what we found out at the
bottom this is very confusing when you
look at this Mike Pence the former vice
president
when he started January 13 when you were
on the podcast he had 5.83 million
followers he today is at 5.7 the only
candidate whose final should went down
2.2 percent so people said don't run go
home we don't want you I'm just giving
you data Governor Christie went from 843
to 875 roughly a four percent increase
you got Tim Scott went from 709 to 760.
that's a seven percent increase Nikki
Haley went from 849 followers to 939 10
increase you got Governor DeSantis we
wanted to make sure we get both of his
accounts his Governor account went up 15
percent his personal account went up 31
percent you got Tim Scott's personal
account that he created went up 180
percent but you went from 174 000
followers to 857 392 percent of
followership and by the way
the reason why I'm showing this is
because this doesn't happen accidentally
I see you all over the place sitting
down talking to people people like you
people who don't like you yet you're
respectful you're confident you're
poised there's something America loves
about you before we go through my
questions would you mind taking a minute
or two share with the audience what's on
your mind you're on the trail right now
so we're all curious to know what you're
thinking about just take a couple
minutes and share with the audience with
your family well first of all it's good
to be with you guys here tonight and uh
I'll tell you you guys out here oh I
love you guys I love the energy in this
room tonight so the last few days I'm
going to tell you a funny story you
bring it up on Twitter I'll tell you
something I saw on Twitter yesterday
was so we were in Nashville we were in
Ohio we were in Washington DC New
Hampshire now we're here within five
days there was this trend thing
happening on Twitter where people are
saying that there's actually a clone
actually because I'm making it all these
events I wanted to prove I know we had
traffic today but tonight proves there's
no clone so I'm dispelling that
conspiracy theory we actually just got
here because a little bit late traffic
coming from Miami I'm grateful for all
for all your patience
I'll tell you a bit about me
my parents came to this country 40 years
ago with literally no money
I've gone on to found multi-billion
dollar companies I did it while getting
married raising our two sons
that's the American dream
and the thing that is remarkable about
this country
is that my story as
successful as I've been it's not an
extraordinary story it is a normal story
in a country that is extraordinary
and the reason I'm in this race
is that I genuinely worry that that
American Dream will not be available
to my two sons and their generation
unless we all of us
do something about it
for a long time I'm running as a
republican but I do not talk about
Republicans and Democrats I find it
boring I'm an outsider to politics I'm
proud of that I'm not a politician I'm a
businessman
but what I see as a deficit in the
Republican party is that for a long time
we have been running from something
This is Our Moment to start running
to something
to our vision of what it means to be an
American that's what I want to talk
about tonight
to me what does it mean to be an
American it means we believe
in the ideals that set this nation into
motion 250 years ago the ideals of the
American Revolution
and I think we have a choice in this
election in this GOP Primary
and the way I think about the choice is
this
there's other good people running many
of them are my friends and you know what
they may not have done as well on the
social media follower account growth but
they're good people okay
but here's the real choice we face
do you want incremental reform
in which case somebody else is probably
the better choice for you do you want
reform
or do you want
Revolution
I stand on the side
of the American Revolution I am not a
Super PAC puppet
I'm a patriot who speaks the truth who
believes that we the people
we can handle
the truth we don't need a government
that lies to us sometimes the truths are
hard
but we can handle the truth
that's the moment we're in that's what
this campaign is all about speaking the
truth that's what we're going to do
tonight
and so to be honest with you I would
rather speak the truth at every step and
lose some election
then to play some political Snakes and
Ladders poll tested slogans
figure out how to win no I don't want to
win that way
we will speak the truth by the end of
this election if I'm doing my job
everybody in this country will know who
I am
and what I stand for and if that's not
what they want
then I'm not going to be the next
president and I'm fine with that I'll be
at peace with that
but so far what we're seeing
is that that does seem to be the winning
political strategy and we're going to
stick to it so that's what we're going
to do tonight we're going to have an
open conversation no filters nothing
been pre-screened I certainly hope not
want everybody taking off their filters
if you want to set it in private at home
in the dinner table say it in public
tonight and that's what I'm going to
kick off my opening with and closing
this off is you want to know how well
we're doing as a country here's your
measure
it is the percentage of people who feel
free to say what they actually think in
public
all right so if you're going to save at
home in the dinner table take off the
shackles say it out in the open tonight
we might not agree on everything that's
okay but we are going to agree that
we're going to speak it out in the open
that is how we'll Revive Our Country
Patrick shares that in common that's why
I'm here tonight let's have a
conversation let's have some fun
fantastic
so by the way uh just so everybody knows
he has no idea what questions I have
here the format's going to be in the
following way Twitter if you're watching
this on YouTube if you're watching this
if you go on Twitter and post a question
you may have with hashtag VT Town Hall
our team is watching the question we're
going to go to a couple questions on
Twitter as well as some of the guests
will be asking you in a minute to go
over there to the if I call your name go
to the mic over there post your question
to the candidate and we'll go from there
um a few things you know first things
first I want to go through a couple
things that is a bit of controversy when
you're asking everybody it's coming out
you know you're you're being asked these
questions recently this one here on
August 1st Fox News reported that you
settled a lawsuit with the world
economic Forum after they fail to remove
your name from its 2021 list of young
global leaders even though you declined
the nomination why did your name
continue to appear on world economic
Forum young global leaders list and what
are your Thai to the organization if any
oh so the ties to the organization are
not my only link was actually being the
chief critic of their agenda so
everybody in this room might not even
know what we're talking about
there's an organization called the world
economic Forum they stand for a vision
of the world called the Great reset what
is the great reset
it's a different vision of how we're all
supposed to live
says that we have to dissolve the
boundaries between the public sector and
the private sector between governments
and companies between nations
to be able to now work towards what they
call the global common good
I'm against this I am a citizen not of
some Global citizen I am a citizen of
this nation the United States of America
I'm proud of that that is true that
means something to me and on this side
of the pond in 1776 we said that we the
people
determine how we sort out our
differences where every person's voice
and vote counts equally in the Old World
Europe it was the other way
it had to be a small group of Elites in
the back of Palace halls in Old England
that decided what was right for the rest
of society at large in this country we
said no to that vision
We the People decide our own destiny as
citizens of a Nation
so that old world view though it started
to rear its head again in recent years
in the form of this world economic Forum
they hold a meeting every year in Davos
Klaus Schwab is the person who leads it
it's basically a view that says the
citizens cannot be trusted on questions
like climate change or racial Injustice
it has to be settled by a class of
global Elites including large
billionaires it's part of why they
decided to name a lot of young
billionaires Mark Zuckerberg Elon Musk
others have been named on their list
so funny thing happens
I wrote my first book woke Inc it was a
criticism of this agenda every one of my
books has specially capitalist
punishment has gone into detail exposing
some of the corruption in this world
view
I went on to start a company strive to
push against the ESG agenda that's the
manifestation of the great reset in our
capitalists in our Capital markets but
then a curious thing happens
a guy who's affiliated with the world
economic Forum reaches out and says hey
we're going to give you an award you're
going to be named on our list of young
global leaders with all this long list
of billionaires and you know Ibrahim
Kendy was going to be on that list and
there's a guy I've been very critical of
so I said no I don't think this is going
to be a good fit for me I disagree with
you all if you want to have a debate
I'll debate anybody
but I'm not a good fit for your list I
declined the award
a few months later my name shows up on
the list anyway it's interesting I got a
bunch of text messages from people
congratulations so I'm a little confused
so I said wait a minute I told you guys
not to add me to this list they said oh
sorry sorry we'll take it off
years later it keeps popping up a couple
of years later and so the people start
asking wait why is your name on this
list so you know what I did I don't
believe in standing by and there are
other good allies like Glenn Beck Elon
Musk others who apparently who have also
been opponents of their agenda who have
been named
but I believe in taking action I believe
in accountability
so I sued him I sued him in court and
I'll tell you a little bit later in a
lawsuit that I filed just earlier this
week against the Department of Justice I
don't believe in just being a passive
bystander I believe in accountability
so I sued him when we got everything
that we demanded including most
importantly a commitment that this
organization would never again defang or
try to undermine its opponents by
ensnaring them on their own lists and so
I'm happy to say that we're not going to
let anybody else off the hook if Klaus
swap tried to put me on his on his list
he ended up on my list and that's how we
roll and deliverance
[Music]
as of today I believe you're 37 years
old you're going to be 30 day on the 38
on Wednesday I believe right yeah
your birthday's coming up so as a 38
year old if you uh become the president
I mean that's the youngest president
we'll ever have in the history of
America currently the President Biden's
80 President Trump is 77 and what would
it mean for your country what do you
think would mean to America for us to
have a president that's 38 maybe next
year be 39 years old why do you think
there's that enthusiasm to want to get
somebody that age as a president
so here's what I will say
I'm the youngest person ever to run for
U.S president in a major party
here's what I'll say is going on in the
country
I think I understand my generation I'm a
millennial
people younger than me gen Z
what's going on
we are hungry for a cause that's what's
going on
we are starved for
purpose
and meaning and identity
at a time in our National History a
moment when the things that used to fill
that void
Faith patriotism
hard work
family
these things have disappeared
and that leaves a black hole a moral
vacuum in its wake and when you have a
black hole that runs that deep that is
when the poison fills the void
it almost doesn't matter what the poison
is actually and this is where
conservatives even myself at times in
the last three years we get too wrapped
up in the symptoms
woke is of transgenderism climatism
covetism
globalism
but it's not just politics or culture
depression
anxiety fentanyl
suicide
you think it's an accident that we see
the rise of these different poisons
right at the same time in American
history it is not a coincidence guys
it is a symptom of a deeper void of
purpose and meaning so
I do think people are hungry for a
different generation of leadership but
today I'm sure there are people my age
who you know may be less with it than
some people who are 80 or 90 years old
who I know who are good for them sharp
is attacking with it I don't think
that's quite it it's not just that we
need a young person
I think what we need is we need to fill
that vacuum by as I said before not just
running from something but running to
something the left will give us this
vision of race gender sexuality climate
and then the right will just criticize
each of those things and say okay here's
what's wrong with that without offering
a vision of Our Own
and so what I'm saying in this race is I
want us talking more
about what we stand for
the value of each individual the value
of this thing we call the Family
the nation
God actually there's a whole the size of
God in your heart and God doesn't fill
it something else will instead the same
can be said for belief in a nation
we're like a bunch of
blind bats actually I don't mean to get
too philosophical tonight but
it's it's the visual that comes to mind
for me
we human beings we're like blind bats
we're lost in a cave
a bat can't see where it is it sends out
sonar signals that bounce back and says
this is where I am
well we human beings we do the same
thing we send out a signal that bounces
off of my family the two parents who
brought me into this world that's true
that's real
bounces back it says this is where I am
send out a signal it bounces off of my
belief in God my conviction in this
nation these things are true they bounce
back they say this is where I am I work
hard you're an entrepreneur and I'm an
entrepreneur we work hard we create
something in the world that is real that
is true I am proud of that that is real
that comes back
says this is where I am
well what happens when those things each
disappear
we send out these signals
and then nothing comes back
right we're lost in that Wilderness and
so
I think that's what young people are
hungry for and we've told them for a
long time
go to Ben and Jerry's and order a cup of
ice cream with some social justice
sprinkles on the side and make yourself
feel good and and that works for a
little bit
but you can't really satisfy a moral
hunger with fast food it works in the
short run but I think right now we're in
a place where that effect is fading I
think people are hungry for the real
thing whatever that is
and so I think that's actually what's
resonating it's not my age or anything
else but as a member of my generation I
get it I was disaffected from politics
for a long time
I didn't vote for most of my 20s I voted
back when I was 19 for the libertarian
candidate I wasn't inspired by the
political candidates I saw I was
disaffected myself so I get it
I understand that
but I think now is Our Moment to level
up and say we're going to fill that void
with an actual vision of what it means
to be a citizen of this nation
and if we can do a good job I'm doing my
best in this race if we can do a good
job of offering a Clear Vision for young
people for all people across this
country
I think we're going to see a domino
effect I think our hairs trigger away
from a national Revival even though it
might be hard to see today
that's truly where I think we are and
I'm actually genuinely optimistic that
we're not
a nation in Decline
I think we are
still as hard as it might be to believe
a nation
in our Ascent actually
in the early stages of our Ascent maybe
I'm not the only young one maybe maybe
our nation is itself a little young
actually
going through our own version of
adolescence
figuring out who we're really going to
be when we grow up and then it makes
sense because when you go through
adolescence
you go through that identity crisis you
go through that self-doubt that's where
we are but I think we're going to get to
our adulthood on the other side of it
and I'm in this to play my small part to
help lead us there so that's kind of how
I think about it I I appreciate that so
let's just say you're on stage and you
remember the uh the the moment with
President Reagan when he's debating and
he says I do not want to make this
debate about the lack of experience my
opponent possesses right okay so let's
just let's just visualize is it
president Trump's already announced he's
not going to do the first debate right
he's just not going to do it he's going
to let everybody else knowing him he may
matter of fact you think he's going to
show up I have no idea I'm cool either
way so so let's just say he doesn't show
up and he's saying everybody competes to
be possibly my VP that's kind of how he
put it but let's just see on stage with
them not the first one second third one
say you're on stage and he looks at the
camera and says listen do you really
think America is ready for a 38 year old
young guy half my age the amount of
experience I've had the people I've sat
down with this guy's great he's
phenomenal he can play a role on Mike
cabinet he's going to say that but you
are way too young to be the president do
you think America today
prefers somebody in their mid to late
70s or somebody in their late 30s
I think the country is ready for a new
generation of leadership I've got fresh
legs
[Music]
[Applause]
I'm excited for this I mean I hope my
best days in life are still yet ahead of
me I mean for me November 2024 that's
not the destination that is the start
line
the destination of the presidency is
January 2033 when I leave office
my older son won't even be in high
school yet
I think it might take somebody whose
best days are still ahead of him I hope
they are
God willing
to see a country
whose best days are ahead of itself as a
nation and that's that's how I genuinely
see it
do I have the level of experience that
President Trump has on foreign policy or
on leaving the federal government no by
definition I've not been in government
but one of the things I might say is
I actually think I am in some ways
closer to Trump in 2015.
then Trump today is to Trump in 2015.
actually
you know eight years from now I might be
tired jaded cynical have a few extra
pounds and a little bit gray a little
gray throwing through my hair if I have
any hair left and you know we're human
beings right you go into drain the swamp
the swamp drains part of you
and I bear no illusions that this is
gonna be some hunky-dory job no this is
going to take something out of me
it would out of every person who's been
through it and I get that
but I guess I'd rather have somebody
going in that still has fresh legs
that's going to come out of it not
completely drained on the other side but
move to a new phase of my own life as
this country moves to the next phase of
its National Life and so are the people
ready for a young person that's not for
me to say my job is to tell you who I am
and what I stand for that's your guy's
job what do you think one
okay all right so question for you
you've been in Pharma you've been in
that industry for a minute you've done
very well for yourself you build a night
I believe market cap right now is around
nine billion dollars you guys raise 2.2
2.3 billion dollars it's not easy to
build a company like that
Pharmaceuticals is becoming an issue one
of the things that I think about Rob if
we can pull up those three different uh
uh Pharmaceuticals I'm sure you're going
to be familiar with current law Brands
current law provides brand
pharmaceutical companies with a 12 years
of guaranteed Market exclusivity right
for biologics and 20 years for each
patent so when I show you this if you
look at the screen if you can pull it up
what you'll notice is the moment the
patent expires this is statista stats
the moment the patent expires lower this
a little bit Rob so we can show which
for uh Pharma this is uh this is go a
little lower so we can know which one it
is what is it Sarah cool okay Seroquel
okay so this is their patent expires in
2011. the moment the patent expires you
notice the price point drops
dramatically all the way down to it
being nothing Pennies on a dollar right
but for many years they make billions on
top of billions of dollars if you can go
to the next one we got a couple of these
examples here golden Lord this one as
well this expired if you can go
um there you go what year is this one
that expires Rob is a 2014 exactly 2014
it expires you'll notice notice the
price goes out let's go to the last one
as well if we can and this last one is
Lipitor prices look how it is all of a
sudden boom 2011 expires dramatically
drops in some cases 90 prices drops okay
which means they can sell it a lot
cheaper today than they are however this
debate with patent law has been going
back and forth for a long time your word
is they're the big Pharma wants to
extend the patent so they can make a lot
more money and be able to say I dictate
the price price point you can't do
anything about it Mr government Mr
President I'm gonna sell it for whatever
price I want that's called free market
how do you in a capitalistic Society
still keep the incentive for these
pharmaceutical companies to hire a
scientists to keep finding better
Solutions better you know you know
whatever uh medicine maybe for Cancer
all these things that they're looking
for yet at the same time not be so
expensive that's making America go
bankrupt and as well as American
families go bankrupt 67 of bankruptcies
today are due to medical bills this is a
real issue for a lot of people totally
is so I'll go beyond the political
platitudes to give you a couple of
interesting insights because
this is an area I know well okay can we
just put up the Seroquel one again I
want to tell you something about that
case
which gets to the heart of what's
actually Raw so is the patent system a
good thing yes it is actually patents
you know where patents are mentioned in
our laws first they're actually in the
Constitution
our founding fathers had the value of
this Thomas Jefferson people got to
remember this he was 24 years old when
he wrote the Declaration of Independence
think about that now this is a guy at
the age of 24 not only writes the
Declaration of Independence
he felt like he needed a swivel chair I
kind of feel like I need a swivel chair
here too well he said okay what I'm
going to do is I'm going to invent it
so you just invented the swivel chair
the swivel chair that we sit on today
was invented by Thomas Jefferson at the
age of 24 while he was writing the
Declaration of Independence so these
guys valued creativity I mean something
was in the water back then we got to
figure out what that is and bring it
back
and so they valued Innovation and they
said that that's a property right and I
think that that's good I think we've got
to be careful not to say we want to
reject something that's been part of our
founding culture of the pursuit of
excellence and innovation in this
country
there's a couple problems with this is
pharmaceutical companies have grown to
be expert at playing games with this
system I could go on for hours about the
games I'll just tell you one funny game
it wasn't that funny but you know it's
kind of sad where Pharma companies even
started engineering deals with Native
American tribes
that they would enter a complex
licensing agreement because the Native
American tribe could not be sued by a
generics company because it had
sovereign immunity in U.S courts so
that's the kind of game playing that we
see now my Temptation then is to blame
the Pharma companies and believe me I
blame the Pharma companies for a lot of
things my whole business was about
standing up to Pharma companies based on
their bureaucratic Behavior but actually
really blame the government
because at the end of the day you have
profit-oriented actors in a free market
capitalist system that are going to do
whatever within the bounds of the law
allows them to extract the most profit
the problem is the government that
creates the opportunities for this game
playing how does that come up corruption
farming the pharmaceutical industry is
the largest lobbying industry known to
mankind and so why did I ask you to put
the Seroquel back up this relates to
real world issues
I'm going to give you one real world
issue that
you're not supposed to talk about right
now
it's what I'm about to tell you is
outside of what they call the Overton
window what you're able to talk about in
public discourse
but it's the truth
slogan of this campaign truth it's not
going to speak truth here
there has been
a direct inverse correlation in the last
decade and a half between a couple of
decades
between the rise in violent crime in
this country
and the loss of psychiatric institutions
in this country
so the thing you're not supposed to say
that I'm going to say I think the first
time in the campaign Trail I'm saying it
but I'll just tell you where I'm at
I think we're going to have to bring
back
psychiatric institutions in this country
if we really care about getting to the
root cause of much of the violent crime
that's plaguing our cities
we shut them down for a long time ago
because there were a lot of abuses we
should be careful about those abuses and
learn from those lessons of the past but
we can't go in the other direction and
pretend like there are people who are
automatically going to snap themselves
out of their
schizophrenic States badly deranged
states that they're in so so why did
that happen
anybody have a guess
anybody have any idea why I asked him we
had no idea these things were going to
come up but why I asked him to put the
Seroquel chart back up there
seroquel's uh
this for bipolar disease to drug for
bipolar disease guess who lobbied the
federal government in favor of the
closure
of psychiatric institutions
it's a pharmaceutical industry actually
so so I think that we gotta be really
precise about what the what the essence
of the problem is is that
when capitalism and democracy share the
same bed bad things happen what I think
we need is some social distancing
between the two let the capitalists be
capitalists okay and that's fine I'm not
an apologist for capitalism in fact I
think we apologize too much for it you
should be able to get ahead through
honest work follow the law however you
want to by providing products and
services to people who need them
Insurance entrepreneur over here biotech
entrepreneur over here I'm proud of that
and I won't apologize for it capitalism
is the best system known to man to lift
people up from poverty okay we do not
apologize
that's cool that's who we are
but where it goes off the reservation so
to speak the Native American reservation
example I gave earlier is when they
start lobbying the government and start
getting the government to to build
barriers that stop other people from
entering from adopt to adopting public
policies that we the people as Citizens
did not want the government actually
adopting
and that's where I think that we need to
let the capitalists be the capitalists
in our capacity as Citizens we have a
constitutional republic let's keep them
apart for a little bit and I think
that's how we will get both the best
version of capitalism and democracy by
keeping them apart not by sharing the
same bed that's where I'm at fantastic I
love that by the way Jonathan uh Karam
if you can work your way up to the mic
I'll be coming to you here in a minute
for a question if you could I'll come to
you right after I ask this question here
so China okay we we learned Yes you
heard of it right it's like five miles
away from here China
um
we learned during Kobe the level of
dependence we have on China whatever it
was the chips cars used cars prices were
going higher than new cars it was very
interesting what happened during
pandemic right with China Americas
dependent on China is an issue for
voters many pundits have said India
would be more suitable replacement for
providing American goods and
Manufacturing how do you reduce
America's dependence on China and is any
of your plan on reducing the dependence
on China having to do with India are you
asking this my last name Rama Swami yes
absolutely yes so so in in all honesty I
think India is part of the solution okay
here's the first North Star principle we
cannot depend on our enemy for our
modern way of life it doesn't work
we never depended on the USSR for the
shoes on our feet or the phones in our
pockets we just did
now if that were a Russian spy balloon
flying over half the United States you
know what we would have done we would
have shot it down in an instant and
ratcheted up the sanctions against
Russia
but because it was a Chinese five
balloon we didn't do it you want to know
why because we're scared why are we
scared because we depend on them for our
modern way of life
this is dangerous for the long run of
the United States
so how do we do it I I would love to
tell you that I could Snap My Fingers
wave a magic wand and we've onshored
everything to the United States I really
would love that there's actually chips
facilities now coming to Central Ohio
where I live this is a good thing for us
this is not going to happen overnight
anybody who tells you it is that's a
false promise and so if we're serious
about being able to declare economic
independence from China to reduce our
Reliance on a foreign adversary then
we're going to have to re-enter
bilateral trade relationships with Japan
South Korea India Vietnam Australia you
name it I don't like multilateral
agreements because they come with a lot
of baggage and garbage about climate
change in there that I could care less
for but in terms of actually negotiating
bilateral deals that are good for the
United States yes that's what we're
going to need
I'm gonna do that in my first six months
in office and then I'm going to sit
across the table from Xi Jinping with a
spine
and he will know that I mean it when I
say listen up brother
we're gonna have to have a tough
conversation here
we'll cut the core we're done we're out
no more intellectual property theft Data
Theft no more forced data transfers no
more turning companies like BlackRock
into lobbying pawns for doing your
bidding year in order to give them
favors over there that's not capitalism
that is mercantilism we're out unless
you radically reform there's your choice
and you know what we've got our other
trade Partners lined up we're going to
be just fine it's going to be harder for
you than it is for us
because you shot yourself in the foot
with the zero code policies that had
about as much to do with covid-19 as the
global climate policies have to do with
the climate which is to say nothing at
all it was about your power Dominion
control and Punishment too bad for you
your economy is now in a tough spot
you're facing deflation so let's see you
if you're actually gonna continue to
call our Bluff because now we mean it
you know what he's going to do
he's gonna have to fold
because China is in a tougher spot than
we are they're facing a deflationary
environment you think inflation's bad
wait wait till what you see what's going
on over there it's because he shot his
own economy in the foot that's the
Achilles heel of any autocrat his hubris
that put China in a tough spot so This
Is Our Moment
This is Our Moment to stand up with a
spine but it takes a leader
who a is not a Super PAC puppet
okay there's a lot of interest in the
United States would rather have us not
pursue this policy
and then it also takes a leader who
thinks on the time scale of History
rather than on the time scale of
tomorrow
and I think that's something we miss in
this country it is a disadvantage we
have elections every two years in
Congress every four years for the
president we need to think on the time
scales of generations right I do not
want my grandchildren or God forbid my
children to be a bunch of Chinese serfs
according to the plan 500 year plan laid
out in China no I don't want that
and I think if we want to be careful
about marching towards that Destiny we
got to realize that every step today we
take in that direction is a need to step
in that direction and I'll leave a
thought with you which
you know again this isn't you know cable
television stuff here which is which is
why we do forums like this but
you know you could say conspiracy theory
no just logically play it forward okay
here's some facts we know
that China is exporting from all places
I'm not making this up Wuhan
not just the origin of the pandemic but
this raw synthetic materials to make
fentanyl
that they're sending to the Mexican drug
cartels now for really cheap prices
that's expanded the profit margin of the
drug cartels that's what's causing them
to push more fentanyl if you have any
doubt that this is intentional then ask
yourself why there are hundreds of
Chinese chemists south of our own Border
in Mexico
right it's a one-sided Opium War killing
200 Americans per day dying of fentanyl
crossing our Southern border 50 times
the number of people who died on 9 11
are going to die this year from fentanyl
crossing our Southern border
and much of that isn't even just
fentanyl it's percocet or other pills
that young kids are getting on Snapchat
they don't even think they're taking
fentanyl but it's lace professional so
it's not an overdose it's poisoning so
now bring that back to Pharmaceuticals
let's tie both of our last two questions
together
if China is responsible for 70 80
percent of our small molecules supply
chain
and they're intentionally going to put
it in illegal Percocet lace it with a
little bit of fentanyl killing
tens of thousands of Americans per year
well you just wait till the moment they
do it with our legal pharmaceutical
supply chain coming from over there as
well and that sounds about as ridiculous
as a bioterrorism lab engineering a
virus that did not exist in nature that
goes on to cause a global pandemic
doesn't it and so I think we got to be
prepared
we cannot wait till it happens we have
to see what is coming that's the kind of
leadership we need anyway let me ask you
this on this topic two or two follow-up
questions on this you talk about you
know when you sit down with you you're
going to tell G here's what you do no
matter what or else you know or Putin
when I you know sit with Putin here's
what's going these are some heavyweight
people yeah to sit with where you have
to be firm yet confident to deliver and
you know make sure they know that you're
being serious about your you know
whatever declaration it is you're given
to them who are some of the most biggest
heavyweights you've ever sat with that
you've had to negotiate deals with and
you know in in the business of coming up
can you name some names some
intimidating conversations you've had to
build a billion not nine billion auto
company that you build Patrick Ben David
scheduling this town hall that was
pretty that was a big heavy guy now I
mean look I mean I've I've sat across
the table from MBS you know it's I've
been to the Palace downstairs in Saudi
Arabia he's a guy my age you know talk
about too young he's I don't agree with
a lot of what he's doing but say what
you will as a young guy who's taking the
reins and taking the nation in a
Direction with a Clear Vision yeah the
sad across table from most many of the
wealthiest people in the world these
aren't guys who got to where they are by
playing soft and I didn't get to where I
am by playing soft either so I'm ready
for the challenge I think that these
guys Xi Jinping Vladimir Putin like some
of the older guys in both parties in our
side of the pond
they're off the top of their game
I think their best days are behind them
you think so I think so absolutely I
think so I think there's some
insecurities there what what makes you
say that well I mean Putin is not well I
mean Xi Jinping is now the different guy
than he was I mean this is a guy who had
you know people who rise I mean you
don't get to that position without
having some kind of chip on your
shoulder right
I don't know how much most Americans
don't know a lot about his story I was
curious about it you got to know the man
you're going to face off with
so I was actually an exchange student in
China been watching this man's rise for
a long time
his father
was actually exploited by Mal's at all
right he was an official in the
government but what Mao Zedong did is he
unleashed the cultural revolution of
young people in China that went after
the Old Guard in the Communist party so
his dad was like abused and Xi Jinping
was taken out with him and there were
instances where he's on a stage had to
wear an embarrassing tin hat and have
kids throw things at him I mean this is
some psychologically scarring stuff some
weird weird happenings in a kid's
upbringing and then now you see the guy
wearing the Mao Zedong suit
right he's trying to imitate the guy who
actually humiliated and in some ways
medically harmed his father put him
through a psychologically torturous
youth there's some psychologically
twisted stuff going on there but there
are also some deep-seated insecurities
right his ego is his main enemy he was
willing to put himself in a weaker
position in substance to just hold on to
that unprecedented third term of power
watch what happened with who Jin Tao in
that meeting where he took over that
unprecedented third term he had who
Gentile literally remember this video
literally uncomfortably lifted out of
his seat
and so yeah do I understand the people
I'm facing off with yes I do
are they weak yes they are and I think
the difference with me is
look I'm an open book I got nothing to
hide we started this campaign what do we
do everybody's always about playing the
game especially wealthy people running
for president how are you going to delay
and gain the tax returns
which put him out in the first few weeks
in the campaign open book have at it you
know that caused some headaches for me
you know people ask the New York Times
ask this question or that question fine
we answered it got nothing to hide
and that's the approach I'm going to
take to international relations where
I'm going to be very honest with people
I'm going to abandon the lie that I
think we've told in the U.S at times
that we're somehow a moral Arbiter of
what happens in the world what I'm going
to say
is the truth
my job as U.S president is to advance
the interests of the Homeland to
actually take care of American citizens
I have a moral obligation to my fellow
citizens to take care of them and their
interests first and so when I end the
war in Ukraine and I'm negotiating with
Putin a deal that pulls him out of his
alliance with China which in turn
weakens China from being a position
going after Taiwan say what you will I
don't trust Putin he doesn't trust me
but we're going to know that we each
trust each other to follow our
self-interest
and we can have a clearer negotiation
than if I'm saying that oh this is about
the fight for democracy in some random
nation that banned 11 opposition parties
and Consolidated State media into one
arm we don't care if beans about
somebody invading another country in
Africa no it doesn't make sense but if
you say that no no I'm in this to just
Advance American interest then two
parties
can reach a deal that makes sense for
both parties and when I make a deal
Patrick I'm in the habit of being on the
winning side of that trade and that's
exactly what I'm going to do when I'm
negotiating trade deals and negotiating
peace settlements on behalf of the
United States fair enough do you have a
relationship with Modi by any chance I
think India is going to play a very
important role they showed the level of
Courage they have by Banning 100 apps
from China something America wouldn't
even do with Tick Tock yeah so is there
any relationship you have with Modi I
don't know him yet okay but you know to
go and I happen to be addressing
Congress the morning before he came for
his joint session so I stuck around one
of the one of the people had me as their
guest and so I stuck around and heard
his address I've been impressed by him
as a leader
at the same time I think that India is
going to have to step it up a little bit
they have it really met the full level
of military commitments that I'd like to
see a little waffely on the trade
relationship and you know understandably
the US has also been a little bit less
reliable than necessary so I want to
Shore that up if you want to think about
a conflict situation with Taiwan what
people forget is the Indian Ocean is
where the Middle Eastern Oil supplies
run through to get to China
and so if India is actually a reliable
partner that is a further deterrent to
Xi Jinping even going after Taiwan and I
think I have probably the clearest
vision of anybody in this race and
either party Patrick of how to deter
China from going after Taiwan while
avoiding War over that island and I
think it's gonna be the most important
thing the next president does from the
standpoint of foreign policy I will say
whether you are the president you're the
candidate or somebody else is the the
fact that your background who you are
what you've done India is going to play
a very important role I think you're
gonna you're gonna need to be a
prominent voice and influence the next
four a 12 years against that's my
opinion but that's why I wanted to ask
you the question let's go to Jonathan
there so Jonathan is a trump supporter
Jonathan feel free to ask the question
from Vivek ramaswani well I'm a Vivek
supporter and uh I believe you're the
best candidate for the nomination
although I think you have a huge uphill
battle against Trump's Die Hard Die Hard
supporters I also like Trump's policies
but I thought you would be a better
you'll be better at uniting the people
how do you plan to win over the Die Hard
Trump supporters
well it starts by being helpful that I
was one and and in many ways I stand by
it
but I'll tell you this the America First
agenda and I think most of the Die Hard
Trump supporters are really die hard
America supporters
America First does not belong to one man
and does that belong to Trump
it doesn't belong to me it belongs to
you the people of this country so the
question you have to ask is this
movement belongs to We the People is
bigger than any of us
it's bigger than Trump it's bigger than
me it's bigger than any one of us I'm a
George Washington America First
conservative actually
and so here's the fact of the matter
that's why I'm in this race
I'm pursuing many of Trump's policies I
am you know there's some small things
here and there we'll do differently by
and large same policies in many cases
going further
use the military on the southern border
not just the wall shut down the
Department of Education not just Betsy
DeVos
but
but for whatever reason right Trump I
don't blame him for this it's just a
fact
about 30 percent of this country becomes
psychiatrically deranged when he's in
the white house and I I can't explain it
to you but it's just a fact it's like a
law of physics in American politics
and I'm not having that effect on people
maybe it's the fact that I'm a first
generation American skinny kid with a
funny last name and live the American
dream I'm grounded in principles not
Vengeance whatever it is
that will allow me at once to go further
with the same agenda than Trump did keep
in mind I pushed his people on why they
didn't eliminate affirmative action
which they could have done with the
stroke of a pen it was created by an
executive order they said it was a
political Hill they didn't want to die
on and I understand that but you have to
play the political Calculus if 30
percent of the country is automatically
against you but if you're bringing the
entire country with you right
hey I went to the south side of Chicago
two months ago I went to Kensington in
the middle of Philadelphia last month
these are places Republican candidates
don't go and what are we finding
people agree with a lot of these
policies actually these aren't
Republican or Democrat bosses these are
pro-american policies
and so I think we have a chance and this
is why I think I'm going to do better
than anybody else in this race of this
to at once go further with the America
First agenda than Trump did but also
unite the country in the process
and I know Donald Trump I think he cares
about National Unity actually he's
misunderstood
but if he was capable of delivering it
we'd be there already
and we're not
and I have a vision of how we will get
there not by compromising on our
principles
but by being uncompromising
about the 1776 ideals that set this
nation into motion
and honest to God right now I couldn't
have told you this in March
I'm confident we're going to be
successful not only winning this primary
but winning this general election in a
landslide which could be the single most
unifying Catalyst for this country next
November thank you man thank you
[Applause]
so how how uh how often do you and Trump
speak
we are all on the campaign Trail
backstage at this event or that event
we're both in Iowa recently at the NRA
but you know probably the same as the
other candidates as each other bumping
each other every every few weeks or
every few months so who can have
Hannibal handy work your way up over
there I'm going to go to a Twitter
question here in a minute but the santis
and Newsome okay announcing that they're
going to be doing a debate
um it's something a lot of people want
to see but the interpretation of what
that is is a couple different things
that you look at so for me when you when
you think about those two if if you have
you know the the champions of each side
you know the leading candidates of each
side debating you undermine that when
you go above and beyond and say hey
we're going to debate each other it's
not like they're choosing to debate each
other on a non-election season yeah so
if they were going to debate each other
six months ago go at it it's great TV go
have the conversational philosophies
it's no problem America love seeing that
but what do you think about them
choosing to do this and the Santa said
he would be more than willing to do it
and newsom's called him out on Twitter
before do you think they are undermining
indirectly Biden and president Trump or
do you think in their mind they're
thinking neither Biden or Trump's going
to be around it's going to beat them two
at the end
I mean I'm proud of Ron he's you know
now willing to engage with people who
disagree with them at the start of the
campaign certainly said he wasn't going
to talk to NBC News and I understand why
I'm in NBC News isn't very fair to me
either but my philosophy is
we talk to everybody agreed disagree far
left far right non-right doesn't matter
I'm not running the league of political
party I'm running to lead a nation and
I've called on the other candidates in
the Republican Party
to do the same thing frankly I think
that's going to make us as a country
stronger so I'm proud Iran for you know
I would say evolving a little bit being
open to talk to people on the other side
or disagree with them I think Gavin
newsom's looking for attention because
he's waiting in the wings to be the
nominee once Biden isn't I'll go on
record saying this I expect to be the
nominee for our party
I do not believe that they will let Joe
Biden run in that case the contrast is
going to be too Stark in too many ways
it will dispel their narrative and so
either they're going to get him to step
aside or if he refuses to do it that's
when the documents case comes out
against Biden that's when the hunter
Biden ratchets up that's what's going to
happen is the reality
it's not it's the biggest myth in
American politics is this idea that the
people we elect to run the government
are the ones who actually run the
government they're not
Biden is a puppet and I think that this
is why I tell my friends in the
Republican Party Stop talking about
Biden guys it is boring it is irrelevant
right this is a puppet we have to offer
a vision of Our Own
and recognize that the real problem is
the permanent State underneath him that
uses him as a puppet or else we've lost
the plot and so in that scenario what
we're gonna see and you're already
seeing a little bit of the jocking for
this is it's going to be everybody and
their mother that runs for that
Democratic nomination you're gonna see
pritzker you're going to see you're
going to see Gavin Newsom you're going
to see everybody Pete bootage you're
going to see Kamala Harris everybody's
going to be you know Bernie Sanders
going to be back Elizabeth Warren can't
strip it off it's gonna be everybody
and then you know Michelle Obama
probably didn't want to do it but
they'll drag her out and you know think
she's going to be the next puppet they
prop up so that's what you're going to
see and so Gavin Newsom is just trying
to jockey for his position because he is
you know hungry for Attention our
California government you think well I
mean that's a wild question you think
any chance Hillary gets in then when she
sees it off she's gonna get it you think
she's gonna get it when Biden wants it
once it becomes clear
that bite that they will not let Biden
run so they're thinking Trump's the
nominee they're going to keep puppet
Biden up there but once it becomes clear
that I believe I'm going to be the
nominee it is going to be a free-for-all
on the Democratic side and you bully me
Hillary Clinton she does you know she's
not going to get that many more bites at
the Apple she is going to seize this
bite at that Apple so that's absolutely
gonna happen that should be entertaining
okay go for it question
is Hannibal handy
compatible if you can get a little
closer to the mic after listening to
after listening to many of your
interviews and speeches as well as
reading your three books I think we can
agree that people on Wall Street in
politics and inside intelligence
agencies have blatantly broken the law
removing them from positions of power
restructuring the executive branch and
administrative state would be a
significant step in the right direction
my question is how are you going to
convince voters that you will hold these
criminals accountable for their actions
if there's no accountability the same
people will continue to attack America
from a different angle I appreciate that
Hannibal so
I agree with you that I want to move
forward as a country but we cannot move
forward until we have settled the open
wounds of the past otherwise they're
just going to keep cropping up and in
dangerous and ugly ways so I'll just
give you some examples of how I'm going
to sew those wounds over so that we can
move forward as a country okay
so first of all we need to restore the
idea of I alluded to this in the
beginning government that tells the
truth to its citizens
who lied about the origin of the
covid-19 pandemic
who lied about what we knew about
vaccines and the risks associated with
myocarditis and the mandates and school
lockdowns who understood the extent of
pervasive government technology company
relationships to be able to do through
the back door with the government could
not do through the front door who
actually understood the systematic truth
but suppression of a hunter Biden
corruption story on the eve of a
presidential election that you had your
social media accounts locked if you
dared even send in a direct message
who wants to know the truth about
January 6th I'd like to know exactly how
many federal agents were on site that
day I'm not saying it's one conclusion
or another just give me the facts who
wants to know the truth about where I
was earlier this week
the Nashville Shooters Manifesto
my view is tell us the truth what I see
in the government today it's like the
it's like the Jack Nicholson character
in A Few Good Men right he said you
can't handle the truth you need me on
that wall no we don't need you on that
wall and yes we can handle the truth
and the people who have systematically
lied and broke the law while doing it
who used our money to do through the
back door fund taxpayer funded research
in Wuhan China for a form of research
that was banned here in the United
States
that's criminal and that deserves full
accountability
I'll tell you another issue which we're
tussling about right now we're gonna
it's gonna be a tough one to sort
through election integrity
okay
many on the left say raising this
question is itself a threat to democracy
here's my
truths on this issue
single day voting
on Election Day
make it a holiday
voter IDs government issues IDs matched
to the voter file paper ballots
do that deal I will do my part as the
leader of the Republican party and the
leader of this country but to the
Republican Party
to say we are done complaining about
election Integrity if we deliver those
Basics that are achievable that should
not be controversial and so I am hopeful
that what seems impossible today think
about the unbridgeable divides
we can do this
it's not complicated
it's simple but it is hard in that it's
not easy okay and that's what it's going
to take is it's not some clever
plot that we have to construct it just
takes a leader with the spine to stand
up and say we will speak the truth we
will speak the truth when it is hard I
will issue an executive order on day one
requiring the entire federal government
anybody who pressured a private actor a
company or otherwise to do something
that the government could not do on its
own we're going to at least publish it
so the public can see it roll that log
over let's see what crawls out
sunlight is the first step
to actual accountability and we need
accountability in order to heal as a
nation thank you for that question
Hannibal I appreciate it thank you let
me follow up on that
um
to follow up on that you know for you to
say I'm going to do this I'm going to do
that I'm going to do this so when they
asked Trump I think it was Maria
Bartiromo that asked them a question
saying hey you said you're going to
drain the swamp but you didn't do it you
hired Chris Ray you hired this guy you
hired that guy he says well looking back
I regret the hired here but Chris
Christie told me about this I didn't
really know the people there I'm a real
estate guy I'm a New York Guy this is
not something I know about
so what do you say to the Republican
voter that's sitting there saying Vivek
we love the way you're coming up listen
we love your messaging your passion your
youth but why would we re-elect a person
that definitely has no experience in the
White House who are you going to hire
who are you going to hire you don't know
these guys who are you going to put in
the office to say well I'm going to fire
this guy and I'm going to bring this guy
and I'm going to bring that guy you
don't have any experience with these
guys in the swamp so what do you say to
those guys that don't trust who you're
going to hire they like you well you
can't fix everything how do you address
that so look I think I'm the best shot
we got and and nobody's perfect but I'm
also going to build on the foundation
laid by Trump I actually think let's be
really clear I think that there's a lot
he didn't do that we would have wanted
him to do but I think he did more than
any president in the 21st century so how
are we going to actually bring the
people in is the question you you don't
want to worry okay well we're already
starting actually how so I'm starting
now I mean we already published our list
of federal judges for example the judges
we'd boy to the Supreme Court the judges
that will appoint to the appellate
courts what did I look at
so my view is the U.S president already
has the legal authority to fire large
numbers of employees in the federal
government this tripped up Trump
this is the difference between me and
Trump actually is
I think the people around him didn't do
him a service by spouting the
traditional establishment Orthodoxy chip
what did they say he wanted to fire
people they said no you can't do it
because there's these Civil Service
protections that stop you as the
president from firing employees
well I suggest read the law
turns out that Civil Service protections
only apply to firing individual civil
servants they do not apply to mass
layoffs and mass layoffs are absolutely
what I am bringing to the federal
bureaucracy in Washington DC and so you
gotta have at once a President Who
is an outsider is a CEO understands that
if somebody works for you and you can't
fire them
that means they don't work for you
it means you work for them
because you're responsible for what they
do without any authority to change it me
and Trump both have that but it's a
separate piece of this which is an
outsider who also has a deep
understanding of the Constitution and
the Hannibal asked the question I'm
grateful he read my three books so
other if other people want to you can
check out the same thing I understand
the laws in the constitution of this
country many passages from my book have
been quoted in appellate court cases in
the last three years about actually big
Tech censorship being suppressed
government action and so that's the
combination Patrick that will allow me
to declare independence from the
managerial swamp class that's the
advisors and then on the Practical side
of this we're already starting we've got
a project
led by Business Leaders right I've known
for a long time already recruiting for
positions not just the cabinet level
who's running the Office of Management
and budget who's running the office of
personnel management do you have
specific names we do we have lists that
we're working down and winnowing down
absolutely and more earlier than Trump
started fine so who are these people
that are helping you process issues I
understand as a founder of CEO we both
run company and there's a reason why we
have a board the board's kind of helping
you with the blind spots that you have
so Trump chose Christie as an advisor
right Christy wasn't a VP but Chris
Christie is the reason why we got Chris
Ray and we're dealing with what the doj
is doing to Trump you know indictment
indictment and mind back to back to back
Trump hire that person right
who's in your ear to help you pick the
right people in these different
positions it's not Chris Christie yeah
so so it's it's a group of people some
of whom are ex-government many of whom
though are really smart people who are
not in government and I have a strong
bias towards that I think it will take
somebody who has a fresh perspective to
actually understand who's going to be a
bulldog in that role here's the mistake
Trump made right you take those two
positions I just mentioned the Office of
Management and budget that's like the
CFO of the executive branch and the
office of personnel management looks
like the head of HR in the executive
branch
a lot of presidents make the mistake of
putting in people in those roles who are
mediators they're almost like
ambassadors for the administrative State
back to the U.S president
I don't want an ambassador for the
administrative State I don't want a
mediator I want a bulldog who is going
in there with a fundamentally
anti-government bias
to see through my directive to fire
large numbers of employees and shut down
agencies that shouldn't exist now here's
the twist in that we will get sued when
we do this right people were fired are
going to say no no we're going to sue
you're going to take you to court this
is good
because the current Supreme Court which
I've studied which I give Trump credit
for he gave us a great Supreme Court the
justices I filtered for should also fit
the same description they agree with me
on this six to three so what do we do
then then we win
now we're driving real long-term change
because the next president who comes
after me won't have his hands tied in
the same way
and so yes I think it is a unique
combination of somebody who isn't
Outsider who has been an entrepreneur or
an executive or somebody who has led
major businesses created thousands of
jobs but also somebody who has a
constitutional depth to be able to act
with conviction without what the
managerial class tells them and that's
what gives me a sense of obligation to
do this thing okay so you know what's
the great thing about business when
business people negotiate we know what's
what's at stake right you're going to
get this much money you're going to get
this I'm going to give up Equity you get
to get an additional board seat it's
very black and white we can do it the
government doesn't work that way it's a
lot of interesting people who look at
you and they say hey guys this guy's
just going to be here for four years
we'll replace them in no time
everybody's just making feel good and
make them feel like he's special new
person but he ain't going to do nothing
he didn't run this country we'll run
this country we'll get him out of here
in no time
they don't view you as anybody right
they don't puppet that comes along
exactly so how do you you know thinking
from the mindset of optimism got this we
got a lot of smart people and you know
these smart people are going to come and
figure this thing out and they're good
at reading people you know how hard it
is to read dark people who have
different motives there's a lot of
interesting people in politics that are
not loving this country the way you love
this country they want their card the
card that gets them into all these
different additional benefits that you
know you may take away from them you
think they're gonna gladly let you take
that away from them I don't and so
that's why and this is where a
reasonable person could disagree with me
on this but I have a firm conviction in
this
that is why we're not coming with the
Chisel we're coming with a chainsaw
because there's no way we could ever
manage to that's a false hubris to think
we could have that knowledge we don't 75
headcount reduction by the end of the
first term 50 of which has to be done by
the first year
yes one out of four will stay by the end
of the first term 50 by the end of the
first year
chainsaw model
that's what I said is there's good
people in the Republican party right now
my I don't view them as competitors I
view them as colleagues many of them
right I'm going to need them in
different roles
but they make the promise of Reform it
is a false promise they don't know it's
a false promise they don't think they're
lying but it's a false promise because
reform is impossible you cannot tame
that Beast it is the Leviathan you
cannot tame that Beast you have to slay
the Beast you have to shut it down and
so that's again the choice in this GOP
Primary is very simple
do you want reform
or do you want Revolution
I stand on the side
of revolution
I know that is scary to some people it
need not be because you know what really
is scary the status quo
and we're not going to change the scary
status quo unless we're willing to
embrace the model of the Phoenix will
there be some cost to this is it going
to be all hunky-dory at each step no
but it is better than the alternative
which is the hollowed-out husk of a
constitutional republic whose stagnation
economically is destined to continue
unless we take a Quantum Leap and so no
I do not believe in incremental reform
okay and if that's what the people of
this country want I think quietly they
do I think it's scary at first but it
doesn't have to be scary this is here's
the test you know to use if George
Washington Alexander Hamilton John Jay
and Thomas Jefferson are walking down
the streets of Washington DC and see
what's going on today
would they be proud
or would they be appalled
I think they would be aghast at what
they see in Washington D.C today
and the experiment they set into motion
that's actually what got us this far so
if that God is here 250 years into this
ball game you know people say you were
like ancient Rome you're the fall of the
Roman Empire well you know what I say on
the bright side of that Rome lasted for
2 000 years if you count the second half
so we're not even at the end of the
first inning and that's what it's going
to take to drive actual changes a
Revival a Reincarnation of those ideals
of 1776. they are dead it's not I don't
even call myself conservative sometimes
because in order to be a conservative
you have to conserve something
the thing that we are conserving is
itself now long gone we have to recreate
that which actually set the whole thing
into motion so that's the way I look at
it fantastic okay can we have please
Johnny Lee Reynoso if you can go to the
mic please Johnny leave you can go to
the mic so that leads me to this crazy
question here okay and I don't know if
anyone's asking this crazy question so
brace for impact ready when asked on the
clay and Buck Sexton show if Trump or
nominee would you consider being on the
ticket with them okay would you be on
the ticket with them you answered I will
be helpful to the country in whatever
way I can but I would not be number two
or member of an Administration I just
don't think that's the right way for me
to make the maximum positive impact on
this country you read for the question
sure if you win nomination would you
consider having him as your VP
I would absolutely right and you know I
think I think that he and I probably
share something in common neither of us
do well in a number two position right I
do expect him to be an advisor okay but
I want to learn from those experiences
where the bodies are buried I don't want
to recreate the same wheel I want to
understand get as much of a head start
and I do think he's a patriot who cares
about this country every bit as much as
I do and I believe he will rise to that
occasion and be helpful to me as an
advisor to understand the experiences of
the stuff he's saying things he would
have done differently great I want to
know that I don't want to have to learn
those lessons myself and so that's the
way I think about it has he picked the
nickname for you yet I think he's
calling me young Vivek young Vivek I
don't think that's a bad name though
I'll take it yeah I don't think that's a
bad name some people some people you
know are nervous about a young president
to me it's it's an exciting one but by
the way if you were a betting man or a
woman what are the chances you think
Trump would agree to being a VP for
anybody
yeah
Jonathan Lee Reynosa tell us your
question hello Mr President thank you I
appreciate that brother
in my lifetime I do not believe I've
ever heard a presidential candidate
mention their desire to abolish the
Department of Education the way you have
while I agreed that the educational
system is broken and it surely is please
explain how you plan on abolishing and
overhauling the educational system when
you become president and especially how
long into your presidency would you act
on this plan
so quickly year one because I think that
your ability to get things done
they go down over your time in office
again learning from my predecessors here
this is why I'm going first not with the
legislative agendas because that's
designed to go slowly through Congress
the pinprick in Trump's momentum was
when Congress was asked to repeal and
replace Obamacare Congress didn't want
to do it and then that deflated the
momentum a little bit so I'm not going
to make that mistake I'm going to start
with what the chief executive of this
country can do by running the executive
branch so shutting down the Department
of Education comes early
I'll go quickly on educational reform so
much to say but I'll give you the the
bullets here basic Redux
shut it down that 80 billion dollars
goes to the states to the people to fund
underfunded school choice programs that
allows any parent to decide where they
actually want to send their kids to
school that's in many ways I think the
Civil Rights issue of our time kids
should not be trapped in the zip code
that they're born into now I'm for
school choice on steroids what do I mean
by that
well it turns out that the schools that
spend the most per student those public
schools have the worst achieving results
on a per student basis that's
mind-boggling so I think when a parent
then decides they already have the money
through school choice through the
voucher to move
if that school as in New York City the
bad one's spending forty thousand
dollars per year per student the good
one is twenty thousand or less half the
difference should travel with the kit
ten thousand dollars that goes into that
kid's account invest that according
normal returns
ten thousand per year that's a quarter
million dollar graduation gift for that
kid when he graduates from high school
it's not even close which is a better
use of money that or a teachers union
Laden bureaucracy which by the way is
the number one factor that shackles
public schools that does not shackle
private or Charter Schools is those
teachers unions get rid of the teachers
unions write the contracts in a way that
prevent public teachers units from
engaging in collective bargaining now
we're talking transparency Choice how do
we get more transparency if you're going
to teach it in the classroom put it on
the internet if you don't want to put it
on the internet you probably shouldn't
be teaching it in the classroom
and then I think there's a room for a
Civic Revival in our education too
and it is my view that
look this is as a first generation
American my parents are immigrants this
is somewhat personal to me
I think that every 18 year old who
graduates from high school
should have to pass
the same Civics test
that every immigrant has to pass in
order to become a naturalized citizen of
this country that's just a good thing
for young people to know something about
our country as that gives you a sense of
how I think of radical educational
reform for a system that's back to being
about the achievement of our students
rather than employment opportunities for
the managerial class thank you I
appreciate that what do you what do you
do with CI and FBI shut down the FBI
hardcore answer what do you do with CIA
said I'll tell you about FBI it's not
just a slogan to me 35 000 employees
20 000 of them back office functions
that's where the politicization comes
from
they're gonna have to go home and find
honest work in the private sector where
there's a job shortage anyway so maybe
it'll be good for everybody
the job Surplus I should say so the the
other piece of this is the 15 000 agents
who are on the front lines some of whom
are doing good work move them to Greater
areas of specialization say in the U.S
Marshals which has been busting up child
sex trafficking rings to the DEA which
has been much more effective fighting
fentanyl in the spread of it in the US
than the FBI has to the financial crimes
enforcement Network in the U.S
Department of Treasury complex
white-collar theft cases
since that's what I was saying earlier
when I say do you want reform or
revolution it sounds scary at first shut
down the FBI I think we will better
protect citizens of this country from
what the laws were supposed to protect
those citizens from but without the
politicization and without the rot of
that bureaucracy
I think on the CIA let me just be very
honest with you guys I'm going deep on
the administrative State on the areas
where I've come out with exact precise
shutdown plans from the FBI to the
Department of Education to the nuclear
Regulatory Commission to others we've
already been very transparent we're
working on the CIA it's a complicated
beast and am I deeply skeptical of our
national security establishment do I
think we've been told to the truth over
the last 25 years the last 100 years in
this country no I do not
but I'm also gonna
be laser focused on actually getting
this right and anything that I tell you
that we're going to do we're going to do
it so in the FBI we have a very clean
plan it's exactly what I'm going to tell
you we're going to do they're going to
be dramatic changes to the CIA as well
it will not be a shutdown I don't think
that that's actually viable or will
serve our national interests given where
we are in our position vis-a-vis China
in particular but there will be dramatic
changes to make sure that American
citizens don't suffer at the hands of a
back door closet monarchy when we fought
a revolution in 1776 to say the
government is accountable to its people
rather than the other way around so
major changes details before the end of
the primary to come but that's what I've
said on the FBI would you consider
yourself an anti-establishment president
of course I mean like the definitional
version of it who's the last
anti-establishment president you think
we had outside of trump
it's been a long time I mean I'm tempted
to say an element of Reagan was
anti-establishment but but only an
element because I think he was and I
respect him but he was prone to a sort
of compromise that
he's a little bit of a I respect Reagan
he's a hero but slightly different than
my orientation coming in as a true
Outsider in this
there's a streak that Eisenhower had
towards the end of his presidency I
think it's what a part of him inside
that disgusted him when he gave that
farewell address on the
military-industrial complex absolutely
but I don't know that we will have had
an anti-establishment president like the
one that I intend to be for this country
and I think our moment uniquely calls
for it too because I don't think there's
been a moment in American history where
we've had the merger of private power
and state power to together do what
neither could do on its own I think that
is a uniquely
now 21st century phenomenon and so I
think that the times of the country
select for the kind of leader that that
moment calls for you think there's a
reason why we haven't haven't had one
for a while
you think that it's intentional you
think they know how to eliminate guys
like you to not be able to compete I
hope not well by the way if you're
talking about shutting down 75 I'm going
to eliminate this I'm going to eliminate
that the last guy that had that kind of
a plan he you know what I'm saying it
didn't go so high not too long it was a
good guy but we joke around about this
but you know we
it was a serious conversation as a
family in the stage that we're in
to
step into the arena that we're stepping
into this isn't I mean we step into the
arena as an entrepreneur this is a
different Arena no question and you know
I mean
I'm a father of two sons we think about
these things very seriously my
obligation is to my two sons
but in a deeper sense of
not just showering on them some
inheritance right I don't think that
does them any favors we're putting you
know God ungodly Subs into this campaign
to lift this up but in a certain sense
that is the inheritance we want to give
them
is a country I want to be a president I
want you all to hold me to The Standard
where you can tell your kids and look
them in the eye as I want to tell my two
sons in good conscience
that I want you to grow up and be like
him whoever that is in the white house
it's been a long time
since I think we've had a president to
whom at least I could say that to my two
sons in good conscience and that comes
with some sacrifice
and that was the tradition I was raised
in it's the tradition of this country
the judeo-christian values of this
country was founded on is founded on the
idea of sacrifice
of doing your duty at behest of
sacrifice and so we all have to look
ourselves in the mirror and ask
ourselves how are we going to make the
sacrifice we need to to create this
country I did not serve at the age of
22. many of my friends did I respect
them for it I went in to be a capitalist
and I think there are many ways to serve
this country and I don't apologize for
that I'm proud of him
but this is a phase of my life to say
how do we
create that country that I grew up in or
even better
maybe even a country greater than the
one that you and I grew up in
and I think yes does that involve some
risk and some sacrifice yes
that you can make a sacrifice you can
take a risk
if you know what you are sacrificing for
and that's the thing we call America and
that's what we've signed up for and
we're not going to stop until we see it
through who was the toughest person to
convince wife parents who was the
toughest person say honey don't do this
yeah what are you doing we're very
wealthy we have young kids leave it
alone we have a good life why do you
have to do this let the other 70 80 90
year olds run just to leave it alone
well I mean the truth is I have a lot of
people we
you know very blessed to live in a
family in a circle of friends who love
us very much
and so the truth is there's only one
person I had to actually convince who
was my wife who was the easiest person
to convince and the rest of them were
unconvinced and did not give me their
permission even as of the day I declared
so they're now along with us for the
ride but you know my wife the first
question she asked me was
are you sure we don't want to do this 20
years from now when it's a great
question you're only going to be 57 yeah
it is your question are we going to have
more experience
and by the way our kids are going to be
out of the house sure and we'll be in a
phase of our life where this might be
more realistic
from a family perspective to handle
and honest to God my answer was I
thought that was a very fair thing for
us to reflect on I don't think we have
20 years left as a country actually not
if we stay on the track we're on right
now I don't think there's going to be
something left to conserve to save it'll
be something we'll be going through the
motions right we'll be still a bunch of
you know two-legged higher mammals
looking around the room we got
you know different genders
two of them there's different shades of
melanin okay this is great we're diverse
we'll be two-legged higher mammals with
a bunch of different shades of melanin
Roman some Geographic space that we call
a country doing what iPhones told us to
do on a given day going through the
motion yeah but that's not that's not
really the United States of America
that's just the aimless passage of time
and I think there's more to life there's
more to this country than the aimless
passage of time and I think that
we call it the American dream for a
reason
and you wake up from a dream what
happens you forget what the dream was
about
you remember what it felt like for a
little bit
pretty soon you forget that too I think
that's the Zone we're in right now
so we forgot what that dream was about
we still remember what it felt like it's
a that's a fragile thing
I don't think we're working with a lot
of time here and so I think that sense
of urgency at poorva she joined me in
agreeing with that and also believing
that you know what
20 years from now we'll be a little bit
more tired you know I don't know that
I'll be I don't know about that you seem
like you were fired up type of guy that
type of guy but you know we got we're
we're ready for this now and so I don't
think we want to look back 20 years and
regret and say that we missed our window
to breathe the life back into this
country you are a formidable opponent
and and it's great to see a guy like you
come through the way you handle debate
sitting down with Don Lemon he's trying
to piss you off and you're like look I
simply disagree with you but
respectfully we're on different pages
the way you manage yourself has been
fantastic and as a person that is as
eloquent as you your background your
ethnicity your success in your life
Family Guy all of that stuff it's
exciting to see guys like you coming up
for for the entire political side a lot
of Republicans are happy to see guys
like you coming up you're going to
inspire a lot of 22 year olds right now
18 year olds right now that are going to
say if this 37 year old can do it maybe
I can in the next 15 years I think we do
need a guy like you competing it's a
very good thing to see anyways I just
want to applaud you for that I think
it's very important so two things if we
can have Heather Hall Heather you have a
very good question if you're here work
your way up there it's a great question
but before I go to Heather I'm going to
go to Twitter I think we've got nine
more minutes left before we wrap this up
I don't know what Twitter is I heard of
something called answer yes it's this
guy bought it he's a uh he's struggling
financially so if you want to help him
out there's this guy named Elon Musk who
uh maybe needs we need to start a
GoFundMe for Ilan because he needs some
finances help anyways so hope Twitter I
I had heard he was probax okay and lock
Downs particularly in Iowa this could be
a rumor that people are talking about I
don't know anyone who lives there to ask
but I want to know what lessons he
learned from the pandemic and would he
do anything differently if he were to go
back I think one of the ones you can
just address what she's saying but more
importantly
there's this conversation about another
pandemic that's going to come up how
will you handle it was relevant right
before it so the first thing I'll say is
I've always been against vaccine
mandates of any kind this is actually
very personal to my experience with the
FDA you think about the hypocrisy of
this nothing gets under my skin more
than the FDA is saying you can't even
have the right to try a medicine that
hasn't been through 10 years of testing
you don't have that choice
because it's not even safe enough for
you to be able to determine for yourself
whether you take it that same FDA gets
in a vaccine through less than nine
months that you have no choice but not
to take
think about that you can you can't
believe both of those things at the same
time so I've always been dead set
against mandates I'm also an evangelist
for right to try that if you want with
your own information to make a personal
medical decision for yourself and you
want to try something even if it's
experimental you should be able to and
even if something the government tells
you is fully approved you should never
be mandated on you because if you have
to mandate it that means you don't
believe in your own value proposition so
I've always been against mandates and
and that's did you take the vaccine
yourself but here's the thing I would do
differently I did take the vaccine based
on the facts available did you take the
boosters as well or no I took two shots
of the vaccine got it and if I were to
do it again I would not do it because
based on the information we had at that
time look I needed to travel I needed to
go places right we have places to be you
literally could not travel in this
country so as a matter of convenience I
needed to get around go to places get on
with my life that's what we had to do in
the circumstances we lived in but even
still if I were to do it again what we
now know with the myocarditis risks and
otherwise I wouldn't done it and I just
think it's important to be honest
there's other Republican candidates in
this race you know literally you know
who have said they won't tell you
whether they took the second shot
come on if you're not gonna tell anybody
you took the second shot you're not
ready to sit across the table from Xi
Jinping but I'm honest about the fact
that on the same facts today I wouldn't
have done it respect Heather please
I love that you're uh unabashedly
Proclaim that one tenances God is real
and ask a Christian my faith is first
and foremost who I am being a Hindu can
you please share your faith about God
and what you think of his son Jesus
Christ thank you so I appreciate that so
I'll share with you my faith and I'll
share with you the relevance that I
think it has to Leading this country
so I'm a Hindu
there's many strains like there are
Christianity Catholicism Etc as many
strains of Hinduism too I believe in one
true God I believe that that God resides
in each of us
I think it is the same statement of
spirit when we say in the Christian
tradition and I did go to Catholic
schools and I've read the Bible perhaps
more closely than most Christians I know
it's the same message as when we say we
are equal because we are made in the
image of God
The Same Spirit to say that's where our
equality comes from it's not some
secular value we're equal in the eyes of
each other because we're equal in the
eyes of God
the tradition I was raised in we say
we're equal in the eyes of each other
because God resides in each of us that
we each have a duty to one another you
got to think about that strand of
sacrifice and Duty that's foundational
to Hinduism
I think it's the common strand between
the Old Testament and the new I mean God
asked Abraham to sacrifice his son Isaac
for God he didn't make him follow
through with it the New Testament
God comes back and says I will sacrifice
my son Jesus Christ for you the people
and so that's a long way of saying that
I'm not Christian and just in my spirit
and my answer to the last question I
will never pretend to be something I'm
not I'm always going to speak the truth
about who I am and what I stand for
but I think it's deeply true
that we share the same judeo-christian
values that this nation was founded on
and this nation was absolutely founded
on Judea Christian values that's a fact
it is also a fact that I deeply share
those values in common and to be honest
does our church does our family when
there is a Hindu temple available we go
for our collection of self to a church
if that's the next closest available
opportunity for prayer yes we will and
so in our tradition we say Jesus sign
Jesus Christ is a Son of God I
understand that's different than saying
he's the son of God
but we share the same value set in
common and I'm not running to be
Pastor in Chief I'm running to be
commander-in-chief it's a different role
right and and for that role I think we
share the same value so thank you
I'm I'm very impressed with you because
I think you act more like a Christian
most than most Christians thank you for
saying that I we have the same values
and that's why thank you very much we
have come to the end of this if you
don't mind taking a couple minutes any
final thoughts you have right now I know
you have some obligations and
commitments things we need to do after
this as well what are your final
thoughts right now going into it the
first debate hasn't happened yet you're
going to be on that stage with everybody
um you know some people are saying it's
early some people are saying it's
already been identified you're now third
place potentially about to be second
place what do you think some things we
need to know about in this season that
we're in going into the first debate
coming up
polls this and that this is short-term
stuff let's think about the long run for
our countries I want to go back to what
I said earlier which is that
I don't think we have to accept this
bipartisan consensus that we are in an
inevitable National decline
I really don't see it that way
I think there's a very good chance that
we're still on our way up
on our way to that Mountaintop
I don't even think we have to be at base
camp yet actually
still as Reagan said that shining city
on a hill where no matter who you are or
where your parents came from or what
your skin color is that you get ahead in
the United States of America based on
your own hard work your own commitment
your own dedication
and that you know what you're free to
speak your mind at every step of the way
that is the American dream
that is what we are running to e
pluribus unum
means
from many
one
that's what won US the American
Revolution
that is what reunited us after the Civil
War that won US two world wars and the
Cold War
that is still the dream that gives hope
to the Free World today
and if we can revive that dream over
group identity and victimhood and
grievance
then nobody's going to defeat us not a
virus not a corporation not a country
and I will acknowledge this I'm not it's
not a fake optimism
it's grounded in truth
we're going through hard times
hardship is not a choice it happens to
us
but victimhood is a choice
and we choose not to be victims we
choose to be victorious that's what it
means to be an American
that's what guides me
I think that was what will guide us and
together with your guys's help I'm going
to need every one of your help whoever's
watching this an outsider like me is not
supposed to do this right go to my
website donate a dollar if you have a
dollar donate six thousand if you have
six thousand think you can't give too
much more than that but
if it's not money even more importantly
volunteer your time spread this message
to your neighbors people are far less
willing to actually donate their time
and effort that's what we need more of
in this country not just to me but to
this country
but if you all do your part I promise
you I will do mine and we will pass on a
country to our children that is greater
than the one that we grew up in thank
you Patrick thank you all for having me
[Applause]
absolutely if we can for the folks out
there it's very important what he said
about going to his website we're going
to put the link below for you to go to
his website the link will be in the
description in the chat Rob if we can
put it there as well but since he's on
the road working by the way he's got a
couple other meetings today I thought it
was appropriate for all of us to stand
up we got him a cake we got him a nice
balloon behind you to wish him a happy
birthday if everybody can stand up come
through you one two three
all right
[Applause]
thank you
happy birthday to you
brother thank you
thank you thank you so much once again
brother Tony this was amazing appreciate
it he's Lifting me up thank you guys God
bless your family thank you
Dan you guys can for those of you that
are VIP hang around I think we're going
to get a chance to do pictures
afterwards I will definitely be in the
VIP room with you guys at the Cigar
Lounge cannot wait to see you guys
everybody else you guys can mingle I
think some of the guys are going to walk
around here to introduce themselves to
you but thank you so much everybody for
coming out take care everybody
[Applause]